fillon relève bonjour on est en direct
ce vendredi midi pour suivre le tirage
au sort de la ligue des champions il
s'agit des quarts de finale je suis avec
sébastien fait rage reste sport au
figaro bojan sébastien bonjour ressemble
on jouera tous tout au long de ce live
bien sûr vous n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions on va essayer d'y répondre au
mieux possible bien évidemment nous
n'avons pas les droits pour vous
diffusez le tirage au sort mais ne vous
inquiétez pas à la réalisation raphaël
voilà nous a fait un joli graphique pour
vous montrer un peu tout ce qui tout ce
qui nous attend les différentes équipes
il faut rappeler aussi que ce tirage au
sort c'est le dernier territoire de la
ligue des champions c'est à dire que on
va connaître les quarts de finale mais
on sera aussi les demies et de forcément
la finale qui suivra moi c'est ça on
sera tous maintenant donc n'aura pas un
nouveau tirage au sort ensuite pour les
pour les demi finales pour la finale ça
va tout sera décidé maintenant et
surtout cette fois il n'y a pas de
règles très compliqué avec des clubs
d'un même pays qui peuvent pas
s'affronter là tout le monde par contre
oui on se rappelle quand même là le
dernier tirage au sort des huitièmes de
finale le rater puisque on avait dû
retirer refaire ce tirage au sort avec
quelques ratés et effectivement cette
fois-ci tout le monde peut affronter
tout le monde donc normalement l'uefa
devrait s'en sortir cette fois ci voilà
ce n'est pas trop compliqué là
normalement ils peuvent pas le rater
celui-là alors vous êtes déjà un peu
nombreux dans les commentaires à nous
dire bayern contre liverpool chelsea
liverpool villarreal benfica on va vous
parler un peu de toutes ces futures
peut-être
[Musique]
affrontement qui pourrait qu'ils
pourraient qui pourrait arriver on peut
peut-être parler d'abord des favoris de
cette compétition est ce qu'il ya un
favori clair dans cette compétition un
seul favori clair non il y en a il y en
a sûrement pas maintenant il ya quand
même deux trois voire quatre équipes qui
se dégage clairement manchester city qui
était finaliste l'an dernier qu'elle a
tous les ans clairement clairement parmi
les favoris le bayern munich inévitables
normes ou death liga
nonuple champion d'allemagne en titre
ils sont toujours là toujours au
rendez-vous qui évidemment il faudra
compter sur eux on peut ajouter
potentiellement chelsea alors celle ci
c'est un peu compliqué parce que c'est
le champion en titre il faut encore une
très belle saison je crois qu'ils ont
perdu qu'un seul de leurs 25 derniers
matches et c'était contre manchester
city
sont un peu difficile à jauger aussi
parce qu'il ya un certain flou autour du
club que personne n'ignore avec le cas
de roman abramovitch obligé de vendre le
club
thomas stocker qui disait je sais même
pas si on aura des maillots pour le
prochain match où ce genre de choses
c'était un peu un peu ubuesque mais en
théorie c'est aussi une équipe parmi les
favoris donc city le bayern chelsea est
bien sûr liverpool qui fait encore une
grosse saison et qui est en train de
repartir très forte en dessous un peu en
dessous on peut mettre le real madrid
peut-être où vivent là où ou l'atlético
de madrid où est peut-être le real et
l'atlético un rôle critique aussi qui
est un peu compliqués à juger parce
qu'ils font pas une bonne saison en liga
c'est là maintenant ça va un petit peu
mieux griezmann est revenu de blessure
il a passé presque deux mois sur le
carreau ce qui lui arrive très rarement
là et revient petit à petit l'atletico
est difficile à juger parce que c'est
une équipe encore caricatural malgré les
envies de changer un peu le style
d'avoir un jeu un peu plus offensif
c'est une équipe qui se conforte encore
dans cet aspect très défensif très
austère et c'est une équipe voilà quand
même un cran un cran en dessous et le
real aussi autant décembre janvier il
avait l'air très fort autant leur double
confrontation face au psg les a pas du
tout rassuré je pense parce que sur deux
tiers de la double confrontation qui
sont pas du tout ils sont complètement
dominés et faux en incroyable
retournement de situation qui est assez
difficile à expliquer pour qu'ils s'en
sortent ils sont quand même un cran en
dessous mais ils ont une expérience
comme très peu l'équipe est derrière on
a benfica villarreal qui sont clairement
les outsiders c'est un pôle d équipe
vidal et benfica pour les autres clubs
ouais un petit peu surtout surtout
benfica je pense qu'il ya moins de
références en tout cas sur la sur la
scène européenne et qui aussi sur sa sur
son dernier match face à l'ajax qui a
montré moins de choses alors que
villarreal a vraiment tout de l'équipe
piège de cette équipe très défensive
très solide qui sait parfaitement
résisté qui sait résister aux gros on
l'a vu contre la juventus 3 3 buts hors
auto exactement et c'est une équipe
vraiment qui sait faire des coups c'est
vraiment la marque de fabrique d'une
énième riz leur entraîneur
c'est quand même vraiment l'équipe piège
après benfica c'est aussi évidemment il
faut se méfier parce que toute façon il
n'y a pas de tirage facile à ce stade là
younes qui nous dit le real madrid trop
son côté n'oubliez pas qu'ils ont quand
même 13 ligue des champions
effectivement on n'oublie pas mais c'est
juste que actuellement et on l'a vu
contre lecompte le psg m'a vérification
ça reste une équipe qui a du mal avec
son jeu oui c'est une équipe quand même
assez assez fragile assez
facilement déstabiliser en tout cas par
par le psg quelqu'un d'assez peu de
repères collectifs et qui a réussi à
vite se mobiliser pour mettre en
difficulté le real jamais vraiment eu de
réponse en tout cas sur le plan
technique ou tactique ça a été très
compliqué il a fallu vraiment une
inversion mental pour que un écroulement
du pg pour que le real près de la main
en l'espace d'un quart d'heure et s'en
sortent mais c'est quand même
effectivement une équipe à ne pas
sous-estimer parce qu'il ya des joueurs
de classe mondiale dans cette équipe que
ce soit thibaut courtois dans les cages
ou karim benzema en attaque c'est quand
même une équipe qui se connaît bien qui
a bien travaillé on l'a vu sur surtout
sur la première partie de saison sur le
milieu de saison semblait avoir de
vraies garanties qui tangue un petit peu
plus à ce moment là mais c'est pas une
équipe non plus qu'on a très envie tout
en fin de saison parce que tous les
jours la connaissent cette période tous
les joueurs le connaissent ce printemps
européen soit benzema modric casimiro
cros david alaba donc c'est quand même
une équipe très bien rodée c'est pas non
plus un bon tirage du tout pour qui que
ce soit sébastien qui nous dit sauf que
la hauteur du real madrid était
miraculeuse contre le psg donc oubliez
pas ils peuvent se faire dès leur demi
finale ou même en quarts de finale tu
verras younès voilà il n'hésitait pas à
débattre dans les commentaires
effectivement eu des mots qui nous dit
vous en pensez quoi du bayern munich le
bayern munich on le rappelle qui sait
peut-être fait un peu peur sur le
premier match contre la rb salzbourg qu
est l équipe a priori assez facile à
jouer un premier match nul 1 partout
puis north plains retour où c'était à
sens unique ouais alors une double
confrontation assez étrange tellement
ils ont roulé sur sur cs bourgault au
match totalement n'y a pas eu de match
c'est peut-être unique c'est aussi une
équipe assez compliqué parce que john
nagl semaine il a pas totalement fait
l'unanimité depuis depuis qu'il est là
il ya eu quelques résultats assez
étrange notamment en coupe d'allemagne
ils avaient été massacrés par par
moenchengladbach et a pris 5 0 récemment
je crois qu'ils ont fait un match je
crois que ça contre leverkusen a partout
il ya quelques petits accrocs par ci par
là
est ce qu'on peut être aussi confiant
qu'on l'était ces dernières années avec
le bayern munich non c'est pas le bayern
munich de 2020 qui a roulé sur tout le
monde les six premiers mois mais c'est
quand même une équipe qui a des joueurs
de classe mondiale a aussi comme le real
madrid a quasiment toutes les lignes qui
a aussi de vrais assurances en manuel
neuer n'a été blessé il revenait de
blessure que ça c'était un petit peu une
idée une des incertitudes au bayern
actuellement mais c'est quand même une
équipe qui acquit à tous qui a tout pour
pour aller au bout sur le papier ils ont
robert lewandowski consignes planer
voilà moi je pense que ça fait quand
même partie encore des 3/4 favori
clairement dit des champions
effectivement alors que le kaiser n'a
pas encore débuté mikaël silvestre viive
et culturel au sort et ancien de
manchester united at raciale français
qui est spécial guest de cette cérémonie
cérémonie de 2010 mais bon
donc on parlait d'une part et du ban de
munich chelsea aussi on en a parlé avec
une incertitude du côté de son président
serra au club qui est un peu dans le
brouillard actuellement ouais totalement
parce que roman abramovitch a reconnu
qu'il allait devoir vendre le club pour
l'instant on ne sait pas qui va le
reprendre on ne sait pas comment claude
va être géré même avant qu'il soit vendu
roman abramovitch avait déjà annoncé que
d'autres gens allaient gérer au
quotidien le club et d'après les
dernières infos en tout cas de la presse
anglaise il y avait eu pas mal de
surprises pas mal d'inquiétude à ce
niveau là des gens qui n'étaient pas
forcément préparés à une telle annonce
et qui se demandaient du coup mais est
ce que est ce que l'autre va s'en sortir
est ce qu'il sera bien géré donc il ya
beaucoup de questions qui se posent et
on voit on a vu en conférence de presse
que thomas ce tour elle était un petit
peu agacé de ces questions et que lui
non plus ne sais pas ce qui se passera
dans une deux trois semaines on rappelle
aussi que chelsea va jouer la plupart
des matchs maintenant à huis clos
parce que il ya pas mal de sanction qui
touche le club parce qu'il n'y a plus
vraiment propriétaires notamment la sur
la vente des billets ça va forcément les
impacter sur la première league sur la
ligue des champions donc faudra pas être
surpris quand on verra des matches à
huis clos à stamford bridge donc oui
c'est un club qui est un petit peu dans
le flou et sur le terrain il ya aussi
une question qui interroge encore c'est
le cas de romelu lukaku tout à l'heure
on en parlait aof je pense que c'est
forcément un gros point d'interrogation
parce qu'il a été hissé retrouver
écartée on s'est demandé s'il allait pas
partira dès l'hiver alors qu'il venait
d'arriver il a du mal un petit peu à
revenir à retrouver la forme le rythme
alors que c'est censé être un des
meilleurs attaquants du monde est pour
l'instant de chelsea s'en sort bien sur
lui ça peut être un énorme atout sur la
fin de saison s'il revient bien mais ça
peut être aussi ce qui va leur manquer
le terrain devra commencer dans quelques
minutes pour répondre à hocine qui nous
demande on en train de ré expliquer les
résultats il faut se rappeler que le
dernier tirage c'était un peu mal passé
qu'on avait dû en refaire a bien
évidemment sébastien qui nous dit je
pense que le carré final sera composé de
ces quatre équipes bayern munich
manchester city chelsea liverpool oui
mais il faut encore qu'il tombe pas l'un
contre l'autre parce qu'on peut quand
même aussi avoir des chocs et on peut
très bien aussi se retrouver avec un
petit villarreal benfica dans un côté
ouais c'est tout à fait possible alors
le même si ces quatre équipes que ces
blessures viens de citer c'est
effectivement je pense les quatre
favoris ceux qui sortent un petit peu du
lot mais effectivement on peut avoir que
deux en demi finale parce qu'ils se
rencontrent tous dès maintenant donc
c'est c'est forcément la petite le petit
facteur qu'il faut prendre en compte on
peut tout à fait avoir un défi qu un
villarreal en quart de finale ce qui
donnerait une des deux équipes en demi
finale ce qui serait quand même très
surprenant si on se base sur ce qu'on
attendait en début de saison à la 1re
équipe jeune et retiré c'est chelsea
chelsea qui va être tirée on va voir
contre qui va jouer tel si effectivement
donc on le disait chelsea une grande
incertitude
avec ce qui se passe en ce moment mais
un club
fakir est l'un des leurs des favoris
ngolo quand tu es toujours toujours
agréable et surtout en huitièmes de
finale ils ont quand même battu lille
assez facilement on peut le dire oui oui
les ont totalement maîtrisé ils ont
quasiment jamais été inquiétés même sens
sans vraiment haussé le ton ils ont
clairement dominé dominé la deuxième
étude qui va être tirée alors qu'il soit
si je pense que c'est le real madrid
donc alors je sais pas si c'est real
madrid chelsea ce dès le début ou skis
ou est ce qu'ils mettent hop une équipe
par omis voilà c'est ça c'est bien ça
donc chelsea real madrid première
confrontation
effectivement gesti real madrid
un match a alors pas avec l'un des
quatre du coup avec un des quatre quines
avec des enfants malades oui on est
quand même sur une très belle affiche
ouais assez assez équilibré j ai en tout
cas parmi les quatre favoris si elle est
inquiète et peut-être un petit peu en
dessous des 3 autres ça serait chelsea
pour moi et je pense que le real c'est
peut-être cette équipe parmi les quatre
noms favori peut-être la meilleure donc
finalement c'est à dieu est là c'est
assez équilibré sur le papier oui c'est
quand même déjà une affiche qui promet
on à sébastien qui dit on verra mais
imaginez ou dans les abris qui gagne la
ligue des champions ce serait certes ce
serait la cerise sur le gâteau pour nous
les supporters du psg effectivement on
rappelle qu'il ya quand même trois
d'anciens d'entraîneur du psg dans cette
ligue des champions et brice dommage
tout frêle et 48 lotis ouais tout à fait
on croit qu'il a qu'il a déjà gagnée
depuis et ancelotti bas aussi il
manquerait plus qu emery et la boucle
serait bouclée pour le bg alors on a un
fidèle de tels mots ferrat qui nous dit
que lors de votre proposition en
septembre j'avais mis une pièce sur
benfica va fé félicitations puisque
effectivement benfica sera et est en
tout cas dans ce quart de finale
manchester city vient d'être tiré pour
la 2 le débat affrontements et la
deuxième au drame sortir pour voir qui
va être le de la deuxième équipe ce sera
l'atlético de madrid manchester city
atlético de madrid si j'ai bien lu
là on l'a encore une belle opposition de
style entre c'est entre ces deux clubs
vous pourrez tout à fait clairement on
est sûr sûr sûr deux pôles opposés
c'est par un très bon tirage je pense
pour manchester city parce que c'est pas
le genre d'équipé qu'ils apprécient
jouer parce que c'est typiquement elle
fiscaux c'est typiquement cette équipe
qui veut les entendre très bas qu'ils
attendent derrière
qui va avant tout s'assurer de d'être
solide derrière
ça va mon avis être un match un peu à
sens unique en tout cas dans la
physionomie de la rencontre je pense
qu'on sait déjà un peu quelle équipe va
plutôt attaquer avec l'équipe plutôt
défendre effectivement villarreal qui
vient d'être retirée villarreal donc
villarreal et benfica se retrouveront
dans le même dans la même partie de
tableau dans tous les cas donc soit des
tirages entre guillemets facile pour le
bayern munich et liverpool soit à double
affrontement qui est qui et qui étiez
possible head
up il ya une deuxième là donc on va voir
l'équipe qui va jouer contre villarreal
qui est en train de tirer en ce moment
et cela va être
le bayern munich et donc voilà
villarreal bayern munich et liverpool
benfica lisbonne du coup
book nous avons nos quatre nos quatre
quarts de finale villarreal bayern
munich on l'a dit bayern munich qui
m'ont un souverain qu'avant
mais quand même un tirage plutôt clément
pour le bayern oui c'est un des tirages
les plus cléments en tout cas qui qu'ils
pouvaient avoir maintenant comme on l'a
dit villarreal c'est typiquement
l'équipe piège face à un bayern qui
tangue un petit peu qui n'est pas
totalement souverain totalement serein
c'est quand même clairement une équipe
dont il faudra se méfier pour le
problème est le dernier match ce sera
donc benfica contre liverpool alors
mickaël silvestre continue de faire le
tirage au sort pour bien vérifier que
tout s'est bien passé c'était patrick
roy sur envoyer vous il faut s'assurer
après ski le ski c'est ce qui s'est
passé benfica liverpool là aussi le
favori est assez
est assez clair oui il est assez clair
liverpool il a fait une énorme première
partie de saison avec un mohamed salah
qui marchait sur l'eau et qui aussi bien
revenu maintenant de la can c'est une
équipe parfaitement rodée qui change
très peu en plus parfaitement intégrée
du gaucho tu as maintenant en attaque
avec la même limite supplanter roberto
firmino
donc oui c'est clairement un des favoris
liverpool vainqueur en 2019 et déjà
finaliste en 2018 c'est une équipe qui
roule toujours sur le même chemin c'est
clairement le favori alors le tir et le
sang est terminée on va continuer de
prendre vos questions on va rester
encore plusieurs minutes avec vous ne
vous inquiétez pas laurent qui me dit
celle ci contre rennes contre leurs
ailes marine une belle affiche du duel
de roi effectivement c'est peut-être le
plus la fiche la plus intéressante de
ces quarts de finale ouais
potentiellement ils s'étaient déjà
affrontées je crois que c'était déjà en
quart de finale c'était l'année dernière
si je me si je ne trompe pas où c'était
en demi finale on va dire jamais mais
effectivement oui c'est une superbe
affiche parce que celle ci ces clubs
comme j'ai tout à l'heure et on parle
qu'un seul de leurs 25 derniers matches
et c'était à manchester city 1 0 ça
arrive à des aléas des bonnes équipes de
perdre à manchester city 1 0 donc
clairement ça sera un gros défi pour le
real madrid qui a montré franchement
très peu de certitudes face au psg qui
peut se poser beaucoup de questions qui
vraiment entre le match aller et le
match retour contre le psg
s'est posé énormément de questions s'est
même demandé sur l'avenir de carlo
ancelotti alors qu'en décembre en
janvier tout allait bien il allait
gagner la supercoupe d'espagne donc
c'est un club où tout peut aller très
vite maintenant sur papier ça reste
quand même une affiche assez équilibré
effectivement c'était la demi-finale de
l'an dernier en fait real madrid chelsea
et de votre côté avec manchester city
paris saint germain et de chelsea avait
remporté donc à partout à l'aller et 2 0
au retour pour le real de madrid donc
n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser vos
questions aux qui nous disent vous êtes
sûrs qu'ils ne vont pas refaire le
tirage a priori non cette fois ci cette
fois ci c'est réussi après il y avait
moins de
de trop de problèmes de de commandes
appelle ça de
moins de gp j'ai perdu mon bras en moins
de choses à tirer c'est vraiment moins
de voix la moindre est moins de
contraintes donc forcément c'est plus
simple nous voilà une rythme du benfica
aura sa douleur effectivement benfica on
l'a dit va jouer contre une très bonne
équipe de la poule même si benfica a
quand même sorti au tour précédent
l'aiac ce qui était quand même une
équipe qu'on voyait en épouvantail cette
provision malgré le peu de référence
individuelle mais qu'il faut être très
très bien ouais tout à fait ben c'est
c'est un peu l'éternel outsider l'ajax
qui revient tous les tous les ans ou
tous les 2 ans de 3 ans pour venir jouer
un petit peu mais les trouble-fête ça
fait une phase de groupe exceptionnel on
avait déjà parlé ici vous avez
complètement marché sur dortmund sur le
sporting il y avait absolument pas photo
clairement le favori entre des pics à
l'ajax et l ajax nous on a vu au match
aller que l'ajax a été un petit peu je
pense démystifier par par benfica on a
vu que quand benfica a accepté en fait
de jouer franc jeu de jouer l'attaqué
bah en fait il ya vraiment des qualités
là dessus et que l'ajax pourrait vite
être un peu pris au pris à son propre
piège finalement
maintenant pour benfica c'est déjà une
énorme réussite d'être en quart de
finale des genres et 38e salle était un
petit peu d'être en quarts encore plus
ils ont largement atteint leur objectif
maintenant soit aussi souligné qu'ils
n'ont quasiment que ça à jouer parce
qu'en championnat ils sont un petit peu
largué ils sont troisièmes jo plus du
tout le titre car ils vont se battre
encore pour la deuxième place qui est
importante pour la ligue des champions
mais cette ligue des champions
actuellement pour eux pour benfica c'est
une vraie bouffée d'air frais on a
tellement qui ne dit bye-bye liverpool
je crois qu'ils les supporters de
benfica a priori
peut-être que ça va peut-être s'arrêter
là quand même pour pour benfica mais
sait-on jamais il ya aussi une chose
dont on avait parlé au début de soleil
c'est les quatre favoris donc liverpool
b à munich manchester city chelsea qui
ne se rencontrent pas et qui vont donc
peut-être se retrouver tous les quatre
en demi finale moi tout à fait elle
finalement hissé il s'est vite tous donc
on peut avoir un tableau la logique est
parfaitement respectée on a les quatre
autres équipes des favoris mais si
encore une fois favori aujourd'hui il ya
encore un hilarant pas beaucoup de
matches rires encore une journée
championnat ce week end ensuite la trêve
internationale ensuite une journée de
championnat est directement les quarts
de finale donc à part les avoir beaucoup
de matches pour ses équipes pour se
préparer maintenant ça peut ça peut vite
s'inverser selon les régions ce week-end
le week-end suivant on verra qui est
vraiment favori entre chelsea l'oréal
qui est là qui n'est pas là je sais pas
s'il ya des joueurs suspendus en tout
cas du côté du real c'est qu'ils en
avaient contre le psg ça va coûter un
petit peu cher aussi notamment un
casimero et l'emmène dit qu'ils vont en
tout cas c'est sûr revenir pour le quart
de finale donc oui en tout cas c'est
clair sur le papier là on a franchement
que des belles affiches qu'ils aient
envie de la regarder donc on aura pour
le pôle pour les dates le 5 6 avril des
quarts de finale aller et le 12 13 le
cardinal retour on n'a pas encore les
dates précises des des matchs s'attendre
à plus tard dans la journée je vais
continuer à prendre vos questions aucune
équipe italienne et aucune équipe
française effectivement c'était
kirishima qui me dit ça effectivement on
a ici on est sur une demain mise assez
totale de l'angleterre de l'espagne une
équipe en anglais une équipe allemande
et une équipe portugaise mais
effectivement pas des équipes italiennes
et pad équipes françaises ouais c'est un
vrai constat d'échec en tout cas pour
pour l'italie clairement pas ce que la
crème des équipes qui voulaient être un
petit peu attendu je pense surtout à
l'inter milan champion en titre
peut-être un petit peu moins la juventus
parce que on voyait que ça allait et que
ça allait mal et que leur première
partie de saison était extrêmement
compliqué maintenant c'est un véritable
échec c'est la deuxième troisième année
de suite pour pour l'italie de ne pas
voir que le bon quart de finale c'est
quelque chose qui leur était pas arrivé
depuis depuis une vingtaine d'années
donc oui c'est une grande tristesse
maintenant pour la france ils sont qu'un
seul véritable représentant crédible en
tout cas aux quarts de finale c'était le
paris saint germain et c'est pas si ce
qui s'est passé malheureusement pour le
pg on va revenir effectivement sur ce
qui s'est passé pour le psg on peut être
parler juste rapidement de l'inter de
milan l'inter de milan qui est tombée
alors je pense qu'il ya une question
tout à l'heure sur sur liverpool
liverpool n'est plus aussi fort n'est
plus aussi peur qu'avant ils ont quand
même senti une très bonne équipe de
l'inter de milan oui totalement sur
l'idée que liverpool n'est plus aussi
fort qu'avant je ne serais pas aussi
affirmatif là dessus parce que je pense
que leur première partie de saison elle
était vraiment très réussi quand même
avec les absences de salades et de manet
pendant la can ils ont réussi à se
débrouiller qu'aujourd'hui je crois pas
qu'ils cèdent blessés ils ont quasiment
toutes leurs équipes qu'ils ont leur
équipe type en fait qui est sur pied qui
est là qui marche plutôt bien ils vont
arriver très très fort
franchement ils ont ils cochent
quasiment toutes les cases en fait même
en terme d'expérience de vécu de
connaissance de la compétition face à
benfica comme un adversaire largement à
leur portée sur le papier en tout cas
franchement ils ont tout pour pour aller
en demi finale et pour vraiment se
frotter hypothétiquement au bayern
munich on a 10 et 82 qui nous dit les
meilleurs que les 4 soit disant favori
le real alors effectivement qui a gagné
contre le psg mais qui a quand même subi
pendant un match et demi et qui a quand
même des gros doutes sur son niveau de
jeu oui kkk des gros doutes parce que
sur le mois de décembre il a été assez
impressionnant justement aussi contre le
contrôle inter-milan les allées
parfaitement maîtrisée sur sur les deux
matches sur le mois de décembre tout
allait bien sur le mois de janvier aussi
ils ont gagné le super l'espagne tout
allait bien et payer le seul match au
parc des princes qui sont quasiment pas
existé on n'a jamais vu donna roumat
pendant 90 minutes où le real n'a pas
n'a pas du tout pesé il ya aussi un
karim benzema dit mieux forcément ça
joue beaucoup ce que le real compte
encore aujourd'hui énormément sur les
karim benzema plus que jamais et on l'a
encore plus vu au match retour pour le
coup mais aussi sur le match retour où
ok il ya casimiro absents ferland mendy
avec quelques petites excuses par ci par
là mais le real n'a quasiment pas existé
lors elle n'a pas montré vraiment de
l'état en tout cas la quart de finaliste
sur ces deux matches face au psg
maintenant ils sont là ils ont quand
même une superbe équipe parfaitement
géré je trouve park allant de celle çi
qui soutient sur tous les leviers qui la
fiv au cours de la saison qui gère
parfaitement son groupe son équipe
maintenant c'est pas pour moi sur ce
qu'on a vu à la hauteur jusqu'ici de
manchester city ou du bayern munich vous
à liverpool effectivement peut-être
parler de ce match pour revenir sur le
sur le psg parce que j'avais eu deux
trois questions n'étaient plus sous la
main mais il y avait il y avait deux
trois questions sur le sur le psg le psg
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui manque au
psg aujourd'hui pour remporter cette
ligue des champions on en avait parlé
d'un mercato xxl qui devait forcément
mais on devait forcément gagner les gens
plus grave que le grâce à ce mercato
évidemment ça n'a pas du tout été le cas
oui ça n'a pas du tout été le cas parce
qu'un mercato ça se juge pas sur le
papier ça juste sur ce qui se passe
après et parce que effectivement sur le
mercato on peut le regarder on peut leur
faire sous tous les angles gianluigi
dans la rue donat roma c'est un des
meilleurs gardiens du monde si ce n'est
le meilleur achraf à khémisset meilleur
latéral droit au monde si ce n'est le
meilleur lionel messi j'ai pas besoin de
le présenter l'équipe sur le papier elle
est très forte il n'y a aucun problème
là dessus mais
l'équipe n'est pas bonne quand même en
fait c'est une question de construction
l'équipe c'est une question de
construction du club c'est le club qui
ne tombe pas on est je pense qu'on l'a
tous vu on a fait aussi ce qui s'est
passé après le match après l'émission du
real madrid avec nasser al-khelaifi et
leonardo le problème il est à
l'intérieur du club il est patent que ça
sur le terrain et on l'a même vu avec
peu de chez tino qui est vraiment pas le
premier coupable pour le coup de
l'élimination du psg parce qu'on l'a vu
encore ils font là par les biens du real
madrid sur un match et demi un match
deux tiers même le pg haut niveau le psg
faire parfaitement ce qu'il faut faire
pour sortir le real madrid donc le
problème il est patent à ce niveau là le
problème c'est qu'il est lui une
faillite mentale une explosion et que ce
psg finalement très fragile que ce psg
arrive en ligue des champions en mettant
le costume mais ça ne marche pas comme
ça la ligue des champions n'est pas une
compétition où se pointe au dernier
moment et on se dit on est tous fort de
toute façon ça va marcher on va se
débrouiller on s'est préparé deux trois
jours avant on ya réfléchi et ça va
passer ça marche pas comme ça parce que
aucune équipe en fait ne fait ça le real
madrid le bayern munich city liverpool
ne font pas ça certes ils peuvent
hausser leur niveau on a parfaitement
que les que le bayern munich face à
salzbourg au match retour où il s'impose
7 un ouh là clairement ça ce droit
n'existe pas alors qu'il ya un partout
au match aller mais il ya une différence
entre juste arrivé et appuyer sur un
bouton et en fait c est vraiment préparé
en championnat en coupe sur d'autres
matches d'avoir montré vraiment au
niveau d'une grande équipe d'une grande
équipe européenne et il arrivait donc
avec des repères et les alpes il ya un
vrai problème de construction d' équipe
de on a empilé des talents offensifs et
finalement on se dit que messi neymar
aime la paix ne peuvent finalement pas
joué ensemble en fait sur un terrain oui
mais aussi parce que cette équipe n'a
finalement pas de continuité parce qu'on
a un entraîneur qui tous les six mois va
être de nouveau contesté qui n'a pas le
temps d'imposer sa patte et ce même pas
tant qu'il n'a pas le temps de la pause
est sympa tu sais que on se demande s'il
le peut c'est ce que thomas souffre elle
avait beaucoup dénoncé au moment de son
départ est ce que c'est possible ce que
est ce que ce psg et coach à bhl est ce
que ce psg est coaché en tout cas pour
thomas stovell visiblement c'était clair
on l'avait vu sur ces derniers mois où
clairement ils étaient franchement il
est en roue libre il savait que toute
façon ils avaient plus envie d'être là
ils attendaient juste de pouvoir partir
je pense que paul chez tino se posent
les mêmes questions aujourd'hui
pour le coup lui il est venu un peu en
connaissance de cause je pense mais là
je pense qu'il fait le même constat on
verra après dans six mois quand paul
chine ne sera plus là ce qu'il pensait
vraiment du psg donc oui le problème il
est clairement à l'intérieur du club il
n'est pas tendre dans le choix des
joueurs dans le choix de l'entraîneur
les plus dans comment est ce qu'on
cuisine tout s'est ensuite c'est bien
beau d'avoir les meilleurs ingrédients
du monde mais si vous savez pas suivre
une recette ses seins en a justement
l'euro qui me dit le mentalement qu'au
psg il n'y a pas d'âme dans ce club très
jeune on rappelle aussi que c'est ça le
cycle enfin sur un club très jeune on
l'a vu avec manchester city c'est pas
parce qu'on construit une équipe très
très rapidement quand on gagne la ligue
des champions très rapidement oui tout à
fait et même sur le l'idée d'être un
club très jeunes ou de ne pas avoir
d'histoire ça c'est pas du tout la
question pour moi c'est pas du tout un
problème manchester city l'a
parfaitement prouvées ils ont fait des
demi finale des finales de ligue des
champions ils sont parfaitement imposé
en angleterre au milieu deux clubs de
très très grands clubs de grandes
institutions donc le problème du psg il
est pas là manchester city c'est une
équipe quitte c'est un club qui tombe
très très bien qui a nommé un entraîneur
pep guardiola qui a vraiment interne et
ce club depuis plusieurs années et c'est
un club bien dirigé ou ça où ça roule
bien où il n'y a pas d'histoire de
problèmes de vestiaires de problème
d'ego il n'y a pas cette course 7 course
aux stars
c'est juste une équipe mieux mieux
diriger mieux construites sportivement
et oui même sur le mercato hockey sur le
papier c'était très joli mais c'est pas
pour ça que leonardo a fait du bon
travail c'est pas ça suffit pas à dire
il a fait un super boulot pochettino
ensuite assez les planter avec les
joueurs ça marche pas comme ça c'est
aussi sur ce qu'on construit au sein du
club et là dessus je pense que la
direction du psg s'est complètement
fourvoyé et kirishima que dit il manque
une vraie direction les coches ne
peuvent pas faire ce qu'ils veulent je
pense que c'est ça qui va nous le dire
effectivement il ya peu qu on peut
parler d'une faillite au niveau de la
direction maintenant depuis de
nombreuses années bien sûr mais c'est un
peu ce que avait déjà dénoncé une énième
riz c'est clairement ce qu'a dénoncé
thomas stovell ces mêmes et un
journaliste du magazine l'équipe dont je
n'ai plus le nom mais qui a récemment
qui en a récemment parlé sur twitter qui
disait que ce qu'il avait interviewé
antonio compter en fin d'année 2010 9
avait révélé qu'il avait été contacté
par le psg et que le comte et lui-même
avaient dit non parce qu'il savait que
c'était les brésiliens qui avaient le
pouvoir c'est en tout cas ce qu'il avait
dit à l'époque qu'il avait nommé marc
déjà marquinhos thiago silva aussi et
leonardo
donc oui le problème du pg il est à ce
niveau-là il n'est pas dans le choix des
joueurs dans même pas dans la tactique
bon après il l'est peut-être pour
pouvoir l'imposer en fait oui à la
question est ce que le pg est vraiment
coach à blaye ce que le psg tourneront
ça clairement aujourd'hui on répond on à
raphaël qui nous demandent est ce que m
est-ce que neymar et m me apévon quitté
le club cette année on se dit que quand
même avec cette défaite de control et
real madrid on se rappelle que mba paix
devait partir enfin doit normalement
partir au real madrid à la fin de
l'année sauf retournement de situation
ce club va être scellé son avenir au psg
oui carrément c'est un peu la question
qu'on pouvait se poser est ce que le psg
a perdu mbappé sur cette élimination par
le real madrid en ligue des champions
pense que c'est oui enfin je ne vois
absolument pas d'issue aujourd'hui umb
ap après ça après ce fiasco après la
situation très compliquée la situation
tendue même les sifflets envers mes marc
messier le reste de l'équipe se dit
d'accord je vais prolonger ou autre et
j'ai franchement là je sais une ambiance
et les derniers arguments qui pouvaient
exister ont complètement volé en fumée
pour me battais donc oui on se dirige
tout droit vers un départ libre en fin
de saison le psg a pas réussi à le
prolonger avant le psg je pense pas je
pense n'a pas convaincu sur son projet
sportif oui il va partir sûrement
horaire laissée cet été et naïma et
messi est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à ce
que ce qu'ils partent plus tôt que prévu
lui aussi alors d'après les dernières
informations en tout cas du journal
l'équipe c'est pas du tout dans les
tuyaux
en tout cas pour pour messi ça serait
une énorme surprise qui partent déjà
même lui en tout cas je pense pour son
ego aussi de déjà tiré une croix
là-dessus de se dire bon ça n'a pas
marché une fois je m'en vais aussi pour
aller où c'est aussi une vraie question
qui peut se payer mais si quelques
clopes mettre autant salir en péril son
projet sportif avec tout le respect
qu'on a pour messi si messi arrive dans
un club c'est pas juste pour jouer un
petit rôle dans un coin c'est pour
prendre forcément de la place c'est le
cas au psg d'ailleurs
ça serait forcément un énorme un énorme
changement pour n'importe quelle équipe
de prendre mais si on sera un peu
compliqué en principe il va rester à
paris et il a eu marre c'est un petit
peu pareil aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
vraiment une idée de départ et là aussi
comme messi tout mon peuple périt et on
va suivre effectivement ces rumeurs de
transfert qui devrait pas arriver qu'il
devrait pas tarder simpson qui me dit
moi je dis oui pour m ap cette année il
va quitter pour le real s'il veut gagner
la ligue des champions effectivement
avoir aussi parce que le real était pas
forcément l'équipe la plus
qui équipe qui la favorite c'est à dire
la ligue des champions oui cette année
clairement ils sont pas vraiment dans
les deux trois favoris je pense pas que
sur la double confrontation ils sont
vraiment convaincus mbappé en tout cas
que sportivement il tourne super bien
maintenant l'équipe et quand même pas si
mal construites ils sont ratés face au
psg mais je pense pas qu'il faut les
condamner non plus c'est une équipe qui
depuis maintenant près de dix ans
revient toujours chaque année est
toujours très fort très solide très
présente je pense pas qu'on est dans une
période où le real pour un nouveau trou
comme ça avait été le cas à un moment
donné aux surtout dans la fin d année
2010 où les voiliers quasiment plus en
quarts il a été pas mal de fois et demi
en huitièmes je pense pas qu'on est dans
une période comme ça pour le real je
pense que pour me taper ça reste
extrêmement attractif de jouer avec
karim benzema avec qui s'entend très
bien de jouer avec d'autres français
fernand mendy notamment
oui je pense que c'est une équipe qui a
tout en tout cas pour représentera la
ligue des champions même dès la saison
prochaine même sur le papier ils ont des
joueurs jeunes très prometteurs et des
militaires en défense vinicius en
attaque je pense que pour mapei oui
c'est quand même un projet extrêmement
sexy on va peut-être remontrer ce tirage
au sort n'hésitez pas à poser vos
dernières questions
on va revenir un peu sur sur ses
affiches
vous personnellement quelle est la ville
affiche qui vous fait le plus envie on
va dire
comme ça j'ai envie de dire que chelsea
real madrid c'est quand même très
équilibré et très très alléchant
city a cueilli comme arid j'aimerais
bien le voir mais j'ai un peu peur que
ce soit ce soit vraiment ce qu'on
redoute c'est à dire que city qui
attaque tout le match et qui se cassent
les dents sur une défense solide de
l'atletico maintenant le viala bayern
munich va aussi être très intéressant
parce que
villarreal a vraiment montré une vraie
solidité face à la juventus pour ensuite
attaquer au bon moment donc à voir
comment bayern va va gérer ça puis éric
à liverpool aussi c'est quand même assez
enthousiasmant parce que si benfica joue
comme lors de son match aller contre
contre l'ajax on aura donc à benfica qui
va vraiment se lâcher qui va dire quitte
à y aller autant autant jouer le jeu
l'otan essayer de profiter d'un
déséquilibre de liverpool
parce que je pense qu'en tout cas que le
contraire vouloir résister au saut de
liverpool et je veux très bas face à sa
lame à neige août à 180 minutes très
très longue voilà ça va être extrêmement
je pense pas pour mes clients et qui
ment bayern munich villarreal on en
parlait villarreal qui s'engagent dans
tout ce bleu yannick c'est quand même
les flots au dessus arriver à faire le
même coup contre contribué à munich ce
sera quand même autre autre chose oui ça
sera autre chose l'année dernière le
bayern s'est fait sortir par le pg si je
dis pas de bêtises et l'année d'avant il
avait remporté la la vina à lisbonne
donc ouais j'ai quand même du mal à
avoir villarreal réussir à piéger le
bayern munich c'est pas une équipe qui
est souvent tombé dans ce piège là en
tout cas en ligue des champions ces
dernières années
à voir en tout cas est ce que est ce que
ce n'est pas une marche un peu trop
haute en fait aussi pour pour villarreal
qui doit encore se battre en championnat
en plus s'ils sont pas très bien classé
donc c'est quand même oui c'est une
double c'est une confrontation quand
même assez déséquilibré là pour le coup
je pense son petit ont rappelé qu
effectivement en plus la finale de la
ligue des champions se jouera à paris
puisqu'elle devait se jouer normalement
russie et qui était de délocaliser à
paris malheureusement il n'y aura pas
d'équipé française en finale de ligue
des champions merci en tout cas à vous
d'avoir été présent pour suivre pour
suivre ce live d'avoir été très nombreux
on va vous on va arrêter ce live ici
n'hésitez pas bien sûr à suivre le reste
de la q2 l'actualité sur le site du
figaro on aura d'autres tirages au sort
avec notamment lyon en en europa league
ce sera 13h30 puis on aura l'europa
league conférence le terrain il en est à
15 heures je crois à bien suivre
effectivement sur le site du figaro et
moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouveaux lives sur figaro relève